such a pleasure
I really was excited about this idea of
giving up talk to the public
I often talked to academic audiences and
colleagues and just thinking about how
to present ideas clearly I think it's a
it's an important challenge and
opportunity for for people in academics
so I'm very excited about the prospects
for understanding how our minds work
that's my motivation for being in this
field of artificial intelligence the
word artificial intelligence is
interesting I often think it the field
should have been called computational
intelligence because I'd like to see the
questions and answers apply to human
mind as well as to the artifacts that
we're studying or building I like to
call AI the study of computational
mechanisms underlying thought and
intelligent behavior now in 1955 when
John McCarthy first came up with that
phrase he told me personally he came up
with that phrase to put the flag on the
pole of what he meant in the 50s
artificial was a very big word I guess
and then we're gonna create something
new that's like humans to find how to
make machines solve kinds of problems
now reserved for people was was in the
proposal now the pole saw is so well
written I think it could be funded today
that was handed to the NSF for some
grant money it's it's timeless and some
of the questions it's asking but a
called-out perception learning reasoning
and natural language as four pillars of
human competency or intelligence and
since then we have more than just four
pillars we have a whole set of
disciplines and sub disciplines within
the umbrella of what they say the
expanding umbrella what's called
artificial intelligence these days and
it's great that some of these meetings
and conferences like machine vision
typically are much larger these days
than even the main AI conference which
is broader in terms of its scope and
number of topics though there's an
interesting notion of the perceptions of
advances in AI versus the the the
reality of the long-term results we
often hear about Watson
and the public gets excited watching TV
and deputies being being defeated sorry
that humans playing jeopardy the
automated driving issues a new kinds of
avatars the alphago work for example but
in reality there's been a constant
stream coming out of the AI community
even defined narrowly so for example in
the late 90s a nice pipeline that
actually recognized handwriting used a
language model to back it up and raise
the probability of correctness was put
into service with the US Postal Service
and now worldwide in the US alone its
handling twenty five billion letters per
year saving hundreds of millions of
dollars and it really just recognizes
some of the in the rough addresses on
envelopes and this is just one of many
many projects but you don't really hear
about you might call these results
running under the hood of our society I
think we care about there are tremendous
opportunities ahead and of course some
already in progress in terms of delivery
of possibilities for taking lots of data
which is now being coming more more so
available and building predictive models
that generate probabilities of outcomes
that we care about like for example what
illnesses are present given a set of
symptoms from a patient or what's the
weather going to be like in four days
though we see a lot of work on
predictive models coming up with
predictions much less work on taking
like inferences about probabilities into
actions or decisions where the rubber
meets the road typically this is very
important pipeline at that point to this
group it's like data to predictions to
decisions and it's not just for
automation but it's also to advise
people who might want to get an extra
boost or perspective from a machine or
from a lot of data set to build insights
in taking action for example in a safety
critical setting or high-stakes
situation now I often say that AI all up
and I mean machine learning planning
algorithms
algorithms that do optimization of
various kinds is a sleeping giant for
healthcare
I've studied healthcare very carefully
and there are so many places where we do
a great job at saving money while
increasing or enhancing the quality of
healthcare as an example a few years ago
back in 2008 our team fielded a system
called readmissions manager was called
Ram and it was it's been distributed
around the world and it's addressing a
35
sorry seventeen and a half billion
dollar problem which is quote through
the US alone it's bigger in the world
which is preventable readmissions to
hospitals within 30 days people will be
discharged and they come back to the
hospital sick again and with this system
is doing it's looking at many variables
in electronic health record and right in
the patient's chart it's using machine
learning to put up the probability of
readmission within 30 days and doctors
can use this to direct their health care
and to create new kinds of packages or
bundles or monitoring or surveillance
like smart scales for example for a
certain illness called congestive heart
failure
and it's pretty clear that AI methods
are in the process of transforming
science and we don't again think about
this all the time but if you ask any
person in bioinformatics for example
what kind of tools do they use daily
you'll hear about probabilistic
graphical models planning algorithms
optimization of various kinds becken
Thank You 2003 Daphne Koller and her
team worked with biologists at Stanford
and they took the Morse code I called
the Morse code of data coming off of
expression of these chips seeing what
cells Express and it's like you see all
these different patterns coming in what
what's DNA doing at any moment and with
graphical models was able to decode
sailer functions metabolism into a set
of modules with sparse connections
between them to get a sense for it's
helping us the new lens on biology and I
have to say that I was floored just four
years ago when Sarah Jane done led a
team Microsoft Research and Cambridge
looking at what cells do as
though in embryogenesis as they go from
stem cells into a final tissue type and
they freeze like your skin cell is gonna
probably stay a skin cell for the rest
of your life and your brain cells stay
as a neuron what's what what kind of
coating goes on that tells a cell when
to how to differentiate and how when to
stop and that's that's what you become
for life for the lifespan of the human
being well it's a big again a big you
look at there at the the codes the
coding patterns on the chips coming out
and they do these time codes they're in
during this unfurling of an during
embryogenesis the creation of a creature
they can do time stamps and look at what
what cells are expressing what to get a
sense for the coded messages coming from
the cells but with a theorem proofer
right with you this is like a logical
theorem prover were able to figure out
that you just needed three inputs to
start or to stop a cell and say stop
differentiating now and it was this was
discovered by a large scale proof which
I thought was very impressive work and
I'd love to say about possibilities
going forward well it's just 2 points of
many points what's happening in science
these days now in 2009 there was clearly
an inflection point in the field of
artificial intelligence when I have to
say I take pride in this at Microsoft
Research Geoff Hinton was visiting with
us and with a small team of folks from
Toronto and we discovered that these
neural net algorithms called
convolutional neural networks what deep
networks for short and deep neural
networks were performing in a mediocre
way back in the late 80s and early 90s
and therefore were set to the side and
other algorithms came forward for doing
machine learning but they were
performing poorly because they were
famished for data they have a bigger
parameter space it's very hungry and we
now we had large data sets available of
the form we didn't have handy in those
days and it turns out when you actually
started a new cycle
innovation around large data sets we had
new kinds of results so the first thing
we worked on most days was speech
recognition and we noticed a big jump or
actually I should say jump down in word
error recognition rates for a particular
data set called the switchboard data set
it's interesting data set it's been one
of the test sets you see how it helped
performances has happened for
switchboard data over the years here
it's a data set of people talking to
other people on low bandwidth telephone
lines collected by an unnamed US
government agency by volunteers who were
told they were doing so and paid I think
to just chat on telephone lines
it wasn't like it's your phone calls for
example but but just last year year and
a half ago we hit a not just human level
now but now professional transcription
level from that data with these neural
nets listen to speech so I say speech
recognition that actually works that's
the kind of consumer view like it didn't
work before now it really works same
methods or similar methods were applied
to a vision to an image net challenge
problem and now we actually have reached
for a particular one of those challenges
also human level accuracy look
accuracies and recently those are
reading challenge I put reading in
quotes because I don't get people the
wrong idea about the understanding of
written text but this is a challenge of
the form Wikipedia articles are given to
a computer and a set of questions and
all those questions answered correctly
or not
well they has a team from Alibaba and
Microsoft came in on top of the list and
near human levels of answering those
kinds of questions about Wikipedia
articles so again you can see you can
imagine even if it's not understanding
text like we understand text you can
imagine these kinds of results imply
that we can do all sorts of interesting
things to build applications with this
kind of competency and then instead of
having just single classifiers that do
well we the community has been building
pipelines putting things together
language and vision for example there's
a cocoa at Microsoft cocoa
Challenge we put together a few years
ago I remember when I was asked by Larry
zitnick I mean Peter dollar if we were
at Microsoft at the time for almost a
half million dollars to build a data set
imagine this data set you've to sort of
get a whole bunch of pictures images and
then have them all segmented and tagged
with human captions of various kinds
because it's a captioning challenge
we're going to now train up a model and
then have a system automatically
captioned photos in the wild it hadn't
that hasn't seen before in this case the
the database was built by taking us a
few kids I've got her over young
children and have them walk around and
just name all the objects they
recognized so I think this is better
about a hundred common objects and so
it's the common object that's the CEO in
the cocoa challenge but this is what we
came out of it that having that dataset
stimulated all sorts of innovative
projects and work and when the results
were reported there were several methods
that came out at once from the
competition ended and a couple of them
were doing quite well I think Google and
Microsoft were quite close and with
different scores one could be said to be
winning and so on but the machine is
saying here this picture a man doing a
trick on a skateboard the human is
saying in purple here
a skateboard is is machines don't make
that kind of mistake is is midair
performing a stunt and so it's really
impressive to see these kinds of results
and then we find out that it was easier
easier than we thought and B maybe it's
a it's it's a folk it's focused on the
actual data set might be over fitted and
people talk about about what this means
for the general understanding of imagery
over time and research is continuing now
so now this Venn have been a lot of
interesting work on looking at video
automatically and interpreting a machine
of what the machine is seen from video
and so on and I've been really impressed
with how fast just I would say the I
would say just but these these
classifiers are pattern recognizers
being more accurate how that kind those
kinds of those kinds of enhancements
have been pressed into service
so at Microsoft for example just maybe
four or five years ago we were all the
edge of our seats at a conference
showing off speech to speech translation
from from English to Mandarin actually
was in China and Tianjin
I was there and we thought it wasn't
going to work in it there was a big
causes Rachid was talking and then it
started working and I remember turning
around and one of the Chinese grad
students was taking her her translator
headphone off her ear with a tear in her
eye as it was Rick ratchets voice
speaking in Mandarin but today we have
Skype translator and other companies
doing that very similar things with many
languages speech to speech in this case
I daily use this Cortana which is
Microsoft's agent feature which is
here's my morning looks like I collect I
boot up my laptop and I see a promise
that I made in email that was picked out
of my email messages and it says you
mentioned to the MS our labs directors
and four others that you plan to
distribute a document this week and I go
oh boy I better do that and how many in
raise your hand if you if you've gotten
this kind of a concerning if you've been
concerned about something you promised
somebody here I will send you a title
and abstract shortly but half the
academics in the room will say I've been
there you know but in this case Cortana
is identifying my promises and figuring
out which ones I'll probably forget and
it's sort of putting them up for me and
and trying to give me a sense for the
timing wouldn't it's the most important
it's daily life and then of course we
have plays high-stakes new capabilities
and I'll get back into this in a few
minutes in terms of some of the ethical
issues but even cars now are partly
self-driving and I like some of these
things always keep your hands on the
real patient into the road but this is
actually the paralysis I Drive one of
these Tesla's I've been experimenting
with this I was talking to someone in
the audience about sometimes it's my own
demise we'll hear about that later also
and then the other actually are tools
available now that you can program too
so Microsoft has
of services other companies Amazon has
appeal on their cloud services but in
this case there are tools you can now
write software and call services that
will for example recognize gender and
age and emotion among other things in
your software so I thought today that
for that background I wanted to talk
about three kind of aspirations that I
think about a lot and maybe we can talk
we'll have some chance to reflect
together with questions a little bit
later at a more general intelligence
master human AI collaboration and
address the influences of AI and people
in society I think all very important
areas of endeavor challenge problems and
opportunities for all of us so let's
start with at a more general
intelligence one that makes me make a
comment that herb Simon and Alan Newell
John McCarthy many others they the
Fanueil Rochester people were that
original proposal to for that summer
workshop I mentioned earlier would be
wholly unimpressed by progress it's
really amazing how slow progress has
been in some ways I think if you look at
the proposal that was written in 1955
and then filled in 1956 to the
government for some funding there was a
sense that that summer workshop that
there'd be some really impressive
progress made in the summer of 1956 that
just hasn't really even happened yet to
this day we really have created these
very very narrow wedges of intelligence
that are almost like savants they're
they don't it's not clear we have
principles of intelligence in the open
world we have no way of really
explaining so many mysteries of human
intellect to this day standing open
questions and it's not clear that we're
closer with the recent work fact I like
to look at the advances that we've made
as ways to frame questions about what's
different about what we should be
seeking potentially given the successes
that we've had and what's the
relationship of these successes to the
mysteries of human intellect so I
thought I'd just talk about a few
directions that I think are promising
I'm hope I hope I have hoped that these
will be will lead somewhere and they
address some interesting opportunities
the first is how we have to address data
scarcity yes we're in the era of big
data but there's not a lot of data about
things that machine's might need want to
know about for example we've had a
really hard time imbuing machines with
common sense the common sense of a
toddler we've had a really hard time of
giving systems the ability to generalize
to abstract we have had a hard time
addressing the magic of the coordination
that we do with all the wisdom that we
seem to have and having it be relevant
at any moment for application to solving
it past what us Billy is that we just
haven't had enough data to build these
systems to understand the world as it is
now alphago in the Alpha work in many
game-playing
projects have made progress the costs in
these games of perfect information you
can have one game play another game and
run that trillions of times and and just
record what goes on in the data sets and
then do various kinds of you know after
you see this back and forth minimax kind
of search this case Monte Carlo tree
search you can collect data and build
different kinds of predictive models
that you might want to use at any moment
which which which which which move is
most linked to a to the highest
probability of a win for example what
move whether the top moves I should do
but we have little ability to do this in
the open world and so one approach is
can we build high fidelity simulators
and actually put our sensors like
acceptors from a drone or a car into
those worlds
and gather data in those worlds but make
those worlds high fidelity enough with
wind and gravity and magnetic fields and
objects and really we know how to model
sensors and these worlds will give us
ground truth so we can collect large
data sets and so one idea is that we can
actually run a system let's say with a
stereo algorithm since we know depth
because it's our simulation we can tag
at any moment
how far away various objects are in this
world and then build a large data set
and then build it in this case a deep
neural network that can predict from a
monocular signal what depth is at any
moment and see how well we do for
example then use this whole system with
its approximations of various kinds to
do planning and decision making in that
world it's a promising direction we'll
talk a little bit more getting more than
a few minutes but how do you map it back
to the real world but you really can't
do this at you know sort of on the
street with a train a car with a machine
learning method called reinforcement
learning without getting in big trouble
in suburbia but here's a car that's
actually running you know in this case
we can run hundreds of millions of
trials this is in the early days of the
runs with an objective function and a
value or said of a value function a set
of objectives and we're trying to figure
out how to get this car to do a good job
and I actually say that um our team is
working with a major auto manufacturer
now so this thing helped how well this
these tools will work for planning the
future of of self-driving cars or
support safety oriented cars that can do
a good job helping humans to drive
better than this
cast like
visual Canada
elliptical power line
and expectant
and for their other around good shape
without touching them imagine 51 also
led to some expecting this car
[Applause]
I sort of celebrate people that brooked
me as well you know that I would say
that the whole idea of simulation
centric AI where we're now in a crashing
wave of this being interesting to people
so Kent this is Ken Goldberg's team here
at at Berkeley who's used some
synthetics or simulation to understand
and learn from thousands of virtual
objects how to pickup grasp objects of
different types and you can imagine if
you can run in simulation and then do a
little bit of learning in the real world
you can really save a lot of time from a
robot trying to pick up pieces of
plastic or objects or glasses and so on
millions of times in the real world now
another direction I think is very
promising
is representing the physics of the world
in our learning procedures here's one
example by tejas Kulkarni pushed me
Coley who's at Microsoft Research at the
time of saying I'm going to actually
take a earning system and inside of that
learning system I'm going to put a
graphics engine that understands
lighting and shading and the rotation of
objects in the physical world as opposed
to trying to learn it all from scratch
right we're gonna use a graphics engine
in there and the idea basically is if
you take a this is a face recognition
task and we're gonna put a few faces in
from a couple of different poses you
know maybe if I just have head-on views
of me Eric aresia I have a side view now
can the system learn on its own through
physics what faces will look like with
different illumination different shading
and different poses automatically
without having to take pictures from all
these angles for example this is just a
general idea of a direction like the sea
of physics the physics of the world
being embedded in our learning
procedures don't get this idea of
generalization and there's so many
questions about how human beings
generalize and how we abstract and how
we we learn a set of tasks and then a
prior knowledge to related tasks for
even very different tasks by seeing
analogies of various
kinds or or homomorphisms or
isomorphisms that are very different
than what a machine might see because it
just doesn't how to generalize one
simple idea that's pretty powerful that
I like showing people I think it's kind
of cute is I hate them use a knife in
any picture here but there's a knife
here but this shows the reputation of a
multi-layered neural net trained to for
the task of recognizing objects on the
image net 1000 challenge train with a
million photos so here's a net took a
lot of time the Machine huffed and
puffed said all those parameters right
and now it can see pretty well pick me
someone's like almost human level the
objects in that challenge set now what
people have done is this is an MSR
project but others have done this as
well let's take a knife and cut off that
top layer that had the final classes of
objects in them and we end up with
numbers a big vector comes out there
instead of being classes it's a little
bit lower down in the network so it's
it's putting out a vector of numbers a
big vector and the idea is to say we use
this this we'll call it a system without
a head to to actually peach would
literally feature eyes images in the
world such that now it sort of has a
general idea about how to recognize
edges and shapes because it was trained
on all these objects and now we're going
to customize it for for use to recognize
for example people in this room I want
to have a smart doorbell running in a
very low powered device some day and in
fact we have a little video here that
shows how this works but the idea
basically is we use a very lightweight
classifier even logistic regression at
the top of this thing at this network
and we train up the model with specific
subsets or sets of information we want
to discriminate which have been been
part of the training at all like rich
Carolina versus Girija for example and
then
we're in a lightweight classifier that
takes all this rich information and uses
it reusing in some ways that the power
of what the neural net had come up with
when it was told to do the original
tasks and he's a little video here
oh he filmed this little setup here but
show us rich running a device that has
that that modified image net neural net
running the whole thing is running on a
tiny tiny microprocessor it's all
embedded it's very lightweight it could
be in a doorbell and he's just training
up you're showing us with a couple
instances you can just train it and then
run it I wanted to show us because which
actually features one of our or somebody
Simon's it's dude Girija who's in the
audience here wearing a head and it
shows how powerful this can be so the
idea basically is can we create these
new kinds of generalize errs that are
lightweight that work pretty well based
on having the platform built or a
platform result that can be refined very
easily with special training another
here we don't think a lot about that's a
very promising area my point of view is
this whole notion of thinking about how
we coordinate resources this has been an
ongoing area of research in AI with some
interesting theoretical results
it was framed by the view of from herb
Simon originally of AI systems as being
extremely bounded resource
decision-making systems in very
complicated universes how should they
apply their resources dynamically to the
best extent when looking forward to
achieve a goal of some kind so imagine
he's a robot and these are problem
instances coming at the robot there's
been interesting work on model-based
very detailed decision making versus
bottle free or cashed information or a
learned model when do see the system go
and step back and go deep versus use a
cached approximation related results are
when you run a system under time
constraints can you do things
incrementally like
better and better over time and then
stop when you have to or stop when the
value of computation the value of
computing goes down or if you're looking
at many things happening and you are
immersed in the open world which is
typically not a single problem world but
a world where results are being streamed
to you what are some results about what
I should attend to given I have a
probability distribution over problems
coming next and we have some given some
assumptions you can actually say some
very very strong things about a model of
computational anxiety what we should be
worrying about at any moment when we
have some idle time but actually looking
at the results kind of maps to the way I
used to feel most of the time I think
and when it doesn't I think about like
okay my assumption is wrong I might just
not an ideal bounded rational agent and
in a twist of expectation for me at
least it's been fabulous seeing and some
of the work and I've part of this kind
of research in this area of bounded
rationality in the 80s and 90s and
continuing to this day
that psychologists now have taken the
ideas from artificial intelligence from
computer science and they're actually
showing example bounded optimality came
from the CS or CS work showing these
results apply to human beings and
they're formulating their projects
looking at computational models and
theories that came out of AI to people
being stressed to see things like doing
visual search for example so that said
one inductions our team has been
pursuing I would call this our pursuit
of interpretive AI the idea here is we
know we have very narrow wedges of
expertise and competency can we take a
bunch of these areas like we know we do
new machine vision well we can do speech
recognition well we can do some language
understanding can we actually build up
systems that are pulling together
weaving together multiple competencies
and then
by doing that and coming up with a
real-world setting look at the problems
of coordination and reflection and
learning or learning challenges that
would make this work better to
understand what it might be to build a
system that's calling upon multiple
competencies as a direction for as a
somatic direction for AI research now
the hint here or the background here is
that there's a multiple resource theory
of mind that psychologists have been
looking at for many many years and
they'll study issues for example like
can I do two things at once and how do
human beings trade off two visual tasks
or vision and speech that probe this
possibility that we actually we're not
we're not single entities but we're
actually bundles of competency hopefully
well coordinated when responding to
different tasks dynamically so one of
the early projects in this space I'll
just give you a sense for how this
research works is we actually with
disclosure filmed the task of
receptionist's at building it you know
at our research building and we filmed
do we have to videoed both the
receptionist face the faces of people
coming and asking for things we can
scribe questions who watch groups
forming you get a sense for what would
it would it take what kind of
conferences top in couple pieces would
be need to actually build an artificial
reception skills and so it was an effort
in representation and perceptual
possibilities and affordances in a
machine we can build what are the
inference challenges this gives you a
sense for a timeline of like people
coming to the desk for example and how
they will form different clusters and
some ones and danbo who's led this
effort let me show you the first version
of a system we built to try to capture
some of these issues and imagine right
now all the competencies that are that
are playing together I'll call it a
symphony of intellect that's been
coordinated
project that's great
hi my name is Lauren and today I'm here
to help the receptionist with shuttle
reservations what's your name
I'm dragon this is Eric nice to meet you
do you need a shuttle yes which building
are you going - I think it's building
nine you sure yes so you're going to
nine right yes and this is for both of
you right yes I'm making the shuttle
reservation for building nine for two
people in case you want to correct
anything say or press start over so are
you visiting someone yes I'll help you
register in just a moment excuse me sir
yes you will be on shell 53 it should be
here any second all right thank you bye
bye hi hi hi so this list of the work
called called the assistant and people
that visit me you have seen various
versions of the assistant huh hired no
one has stopped by to see you since we
last talked and outlook mobile manager
is still down so I'm not seeing messages
from your emails and reflection they're
about actually getting lost and so my
wife and I love showing this picture
because this was somebody who during
this phase of the system it's gotten
better since then and has many different
dimensions in terms of its domain
knowledge including about 17 years of my
comings and goings that have been
recorded so for timing and forecasting
and someone almost better than Sarah
reading my human Edmund knows my comings
and goings and this young lady came to
see me one day she's given me permission
to use this video she was an intern
leaving wanted to talk to what she left
and I thought it's interesting to watch
her face up to this system and interact
with the system for the first time being
a little nervous
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so I think this interesting promise in
this direction but but progress has been
very very slow and doesn't mean we can't
build really interesting helpful tools
and that's we're going next in this area
aspiration of mastering human a
collaboration there are several
directions here how do we build systems
that can really extend people that can
augment our intelligence that can catch
errors that we make and it takes
understanding and these are separate
areas of research to come together
models of people and their tasks models
of complementarity and coordinating
initiative and the model of my mind that
I like to think about when I think about
possibilities is that human beings their
abilities here on the y-axis and we can
look at our competencies as being almost
magical we're very powerful but we have
systematic blind spots and biases and
gaps in our abilities
and cognitive psychologists have studied
these gaps for over 100 years
and here's the vision right not just in
general like a paper and pencil helps
extend our minds but could we actually
understand these gaps well enough to use
machine intellect to extend us where we
need it the most
not replace us but extend us right and
there's been working on special pillars
of psychology memory attention and
judgment for example this is a very
promising or it's very exciting to our
team many of you know that there's some
great working in psychology for example
famous work on your wristt expand biases
you know people just don't understand
for example prior probabilities of
outcomes there's an availability bias
representative bias these are very well
known you can imagine a machine that
knows about people's biases might be
able to help us in various situations
even more detailed there's really great
work on issues about multitasking for
example like that help us understand the
challenge of driving a car while being
on the phone this is actually one of our
projects in our group the attention
operating characteristic curve release
gives us a sense for the human trades
across people that we make in trying to
do two things at once our team has done
work over the last almost 20 years in
attention memory and judgment for
example on the upper left-hand side we
put modules that at any moment would
compute the cost of interrupting
somebody this is a machine learning
model with with type of interruption X
what will people forget what will they
remember as landmarks what will surprise
them
for example traffic application
memorability if you had a model of what
you remember you can imagine a big
timeline that would just light up with a
probe with a probe list ik inference the
landmarks in your life they help you
navigate a line at the hot time line of
everything you've done for example so
you can imagine these kinds of tools to
be used in different applications and so
on but more generally we could think
about a couple mentality and start very
basic so there was a chameleon grand
challenge in 2016 the challenge was
here's a big data set
of negatives and positives positives are
in this lymph node tick tissue is
histology for pathologists to look at
there are signs of metastatic breast
cancer and it turned out that maybe it's
good news for pathology humans were
superior to the best machine learned
model everyone here sigh of relief in
the 2018 a sigh of relief for the
audience yes humans were better but it
turns out the human era was 3.4 percent
and it's false positives and false
negatives but when you combined in a
very simple way the AI system and the
expert the best neural network you can
reduce errors by 85% so in a simple
combination running both machines
together or the machines I thinking I'm
actually sharing sharing my my own
Intuit insight here about that my bias
running humans and machines together we
end up with a better combination but we
can do better than that so as an example
Ajay Kumar and I looked with Severin
hacker look at this interesting
crowdsourcing project label these
galaxies it's part of this project
called Zooniverse and we said instead of
and use lots of people to come online
and sort of help become citizen
scientists like astronomers and help
label galaxies because they're in the
Sloan Sky Survey there are millions of
galaxies that astronomers don't have
time to look at so we said I wouldn't be
if we had machine vision and humans
working together how well we do and from
a large data set we learned a model you
call this this is a machine learn model
that brings together people's abilities
and machines abilities looking at the
details of the mission of the imagery or
the features being seen in each galaxy
and someone's history and background and
the current votes coming in from humans
to decide how much will be worth to
bring a human being to help here how
many more people should we bring in
versus not and it turns out by doing
this well with a whole planner and so on
you money call it research we showed you
can get full accuracy of all the humans
working on this for half the human
effort
and 0.95 accuracy or 95% at the quarter
of the effort while working now with it
with a student and he just had his is a
proposal defense just this week is on
catching human errors in health care now
there's been various studies in health
care about preventable errors and
outcomes adverse outcomes in medicine in
around 2000 the use T of Medicine found
that about a hundred thousand people
were dying in hospitals because of
preventable human error in a report
labeled to err is human and it is have
traffic accidents as human as well there
we can't people make mistakes
the British Medical Journal published a
piece about five years ago
that said no actually medical error
preventable medical error is is
basically the source of over a quarter
of a million deaths per year in
hospitals in the US alone now this has
been disputed and is back and forth on
this but it's a big number they put it
as a third cause of death after cancer
and heart disease
so could AI systems capture like a
safety net some of these errors and save
many many lives and I think the answer
to that is yes here's a simple model
that I want to talk to you about that I
think it captures the direction I'd like
to see AI go it's a big opportunity
space imagine a data set acquired from a
hospital one of the top 10 urban
hospitals we were working with on the
east coast of the form I have a lot of
patients over 15 years of data who were
discharged from the emergency room and
they came back within 48 hours and they
were admitted to the hospital very sick
with a primary diagnosis that was
located nowhere at discharge time on the
chart so I we labeled those kind of
situations as surprises for an expert so
these are not like help me diagnose this
and I couldn't know how to do it's like
find me cases that surprised expert
physicians and now build a model that
when it runs at discharge time will
compute the likelihood that this patient
this one here will surprise the doctor
in some way by some pattern of symptoms
of hiding in the shadows of cognition so
it's it's by definition it's running at
the frontiers of human knowledge versus
trying to replicate people that's kind
of an interesting direction and these
days we're pushing this harder into this
area of failure to rescue which is a
really sad phrase which means something
that happened with this patient in the
hospital that could have been treated to
stop a cascade towards death was missed
failure to rescue
and so daily and I you dub student we
have a large database of deaths in the
UW System if people who came in for
elective procedures like I can try that
out and then never left the hospital
what didn't leave alive can we figure
out what happened to these patients and
why and could an AI system trained on a
lot of data help doctors do a better job
now finally I just want to mention that
beyond this complementarity is that the
how when you mix human and machine
intelligence together
what's the mix of initiatives and how
does that work and you can imagine this
happening in a variety of ways if we
have more time today I would show some
surgical videos showing how a robot
works for the human being hand in hand
where coordination is critical timing
but let me just jump to back to my
assistants again and show you a little
bit of a grounding issue here or
initiative and conversation where
conversation psychologists view is as a
collaboration where people make
contributions so what you see here is a
trace of the assistant by my door the
latest version in fact and it's hard to
decode what you see here are
representations of uncertainty in what's
being seen what's being heard what's
being understood who goes next and
domain knowledge and
Asia was an intern with us we decided
let's take this really important set of
information and provided as natural
signals to a human being in conversation
to help with the collaboration you would
have in a conversation and here's how
that works I'm just gonna start out
without sound but just watch this is the
latest version of the assistant so watch
what happens as they come to my door but
watch your facial expressions very
carefully they all driven
algorithmically are you here for the
2:00 o'clock meeting with Zack sorry did
you say you were here for the 2:00
o'clock meeting with Zack yes is one of
you John yes sorry I can't tell who is
speaking when you stand so close
together which one of you said there
John I did right hi John Zack is
expecting you will you be joining the
meeting sir
sorry will you be joining the meeting
yes all right
I've let it suck know you'll be joining
his meeting with John I'm sorry I think
that he's running a little bit late I'm
pretty sure he's on his way just to be
safe I'll send him a note to let him
know that you're here feel free to have
a seat while you wait for him guess I'll
see you later then bye bye so what I
love about this is um and it gives me
little tingles up my spine is it's the
fact the probably the first time we're
taking all these inferences about
multiple uncertainties across perception
and knowledge and we're sharing it out
those the sexually entropy signals on
cross each of these channels we're
sharing it out through facial expression
yeah oh not in a natural way let me move
on to to the to the influences of AI
people in society I don't want to have
time to spend to go into depth in this
area but I think it's a great way to
frame Q&A
and if you this is talking about maybe
some of the rough edges we need to get
right as well as potential costs over
time some quite serious I was amazed
that these headlines are just all about
two months old I mean it within two
months
these heavens have appeared in the press
all addressing different distinctions
and issues coming up with automation in
our midst rising very quickly this
latest one interesting justice came up
last week about you know sort of
algorithmically adds an hour you know
extremist videos are sucking attention
and also sucking ad revenue and so on
and so there are challenges that we
bring AI into the open world and the way
I'd like to think about this is
challenges with capabilities of AI
systems their abilities blind spots and
biases issues around values whose values
represented in the systems in terms of
the alignment of the objectives of a
human being or an enterprise with the
system's values how they represented
when I say agency that means who's the
decision being made for or who owns the
decision typically in health care for
example we say the page that the patient
is the principal agent of any medical
decision misuse it was recently a story
about a of an arrest in a country where
a facial recognition facial recognition
by report a facial recognition system
was aimed at a large stadium full of
people at a rock concert to identify
somebody wanted for a crime these kinds
of powers coming to be AI systems are
interesting and concerning risks to core
human rights freedom of expression
freedom to assemble freedom to of speech
there are other kinds of challenges
coming to the fore including privacy
data is the fuel of these systems
various kinds of harms exclusion
attention persuasion of systems
algorithms persuasion for example about
beliefs for example and one often
unstated principle when I asked myself
well why weren't these big concerns
fifteen years ago when I was a Stanford
student or 20 years ago I think I'm
under estimating these numbers actually
now 25 years ago when successes in AI
would be new insights about mind and
they'd be new possibilities for service
to humanity and one of the issues that
comes to my mind is that because these
systems are now quickly brought to scale
and they're reusable we see immediate
potential amplification through wide and
deep societal influences so I had right
now in the back of my mind I see this
Network showing up which is if I build
an app like that medical app that those
readmissions it might go to a thousand
hospitals so now it's just that not one
expert system being used by one doctor
it has could have major societal
implications or a traffic system it's
making recommendations on a wide scale
over a city for example we need to think
about this moving forward just what I
mentioned some about misuses I mentioned
a bit a bit about this but we have as I
said Yuman rights violations that are
possible risk of death or serious injury
we've seen that in the press lately with
automation that that might we might do
better at these systems can be at the
root of the denial of critical resources
like loans output entry to schools
education and so on and they can
manipulate attention beliefs and in
cognition is there any way
now I do believe that we all have
responsibility academia corporations the
civil society realm to focus our
attention on these rough edges given how
fast these effects and influences are
coming into our society at Microsoft we
created the ether committee which
loosely stands for AI epics and effects
in engineering and research with seven
working groups now including working
groups looking very carefully at
potential human rights issues coming to
the fore with Microsoft software and
services and uses and making
recommendations to senior leadership of
Microsoft Microsoft Corporation like
others has made commitments based on
some UN reports and charters including
the core human rights charter but much
of has its own a statement about human
rights commitments yeah we still want to
stick with when it comes to the possible
misuse of AI technologies another
software uses and then on the community
side it's really nice to see and I've
been involved with this has been great a
great collaboration to form a non-profit
a multi-party stakeholder group called
the partnership on AI that started out
as a conversation among researchers at
the research labs will Voigt all very
good friends over the years from grad
school days and on at amazon google
deepmind Microsoft Facebook Apple and
IBM to say that's former nonprofit let's
invite our colleagues from from this
from civil society academia nonprofit AI
research economics research and service
and foundation work and build a balanced
board that balances six seats for the in
this case daunting companies and six
seats for distribution of nonprofit
and we just bought on a few months ago
Tara Lyons to be executive director
people might recognize her as being very
active during the Obama administration's
OSTP efforts on AI and this group is all
about providing a platform for
discussions and working groups
developing best practices across
industry and civil society and being a
place where people can really discuss
and work through some of these rough
edges over time so I want to end by just
saying that my dream and my passions are
all about number one largely I want to
understand what's going on with this
graph this tangle of neurons that's Eric
Horvitz I'm fascinated by that I have
some insights that I have managed to
accrue over the years largely from the
AI research even though we don't have a
lot to say about this just yet we don't
I love the idea of as a community
welcome to take these results and
delivering value to people in society we
need to continue to identify and address
costs and ethical issues with new kinds
of automation coming to the fore and
being amplified by network effects the
web and our connectivity throughout the
world now and it's really important that
these collaborations on these issues
both technical and societal happen
widely with multiple stakeholders and
their inputs and feedback and leadership
so I'll stop there and we'll go to Q&A
thank you very much
[Applause]
you very much was great and inspiring
now if you have questions please please
raise your hand
someone will come with a microphone and
when you have the microphone you can ask
your questions so this is really big so
thank you very much for the presentation
in fact it's so big it kind of reminds
me of the Internet in the 1990s twenty
years ago so I've asked people who are
experts in this is this going to be
equal in size to the Internet and
importance and impact on society or is
it going to be even bigger than the
Internet
what's your opinion it's an interesting
question and the metrics have to Center
figure out what the metrics becomes a
bigger impact on society I always say ok
boy that's it that's a tough one the
connectivity and influence of the
Internet is so incredible and so deep
and so unexpected to me putting myself
in my grad school shoes of somebody
using some X aimed that DARPA that ARPA
dot you know that whatever it was in
those days I guess that art but and it
depends how it goes I would say you know
we might be mostly dealing with
classifiers and pattern recognizers for
there for decades and but I came from a
meeting this morning with several folks
I won't give away details of this that
we had different opinions on what's
going to happen over the next 15 years
with these technologies and if some
people to me to go correct the answers
your question is absolutely I'll leave
it there
yeah microphone here you come have you
worked with people working on deep voice
at all and better text-to-speech because
your assistant is very good at
processing and understanding but it's
not a great talker
yes thanks is a good question so so let
me just make a comment that we don't
have and it's a great one we don't have
best of a breed in almost any component
in that system so what's the magical
part of that research project was there
was like well it was probably time to
get a better version of X because it's
like a six year old system before the
deep voice was there and the other
competitors and so on let me just say
that I want to celebrate Julia
Hirschberg was just became a National
Academy of Engineering member last maybe
two years ago now for this incredible
breakthrough work that gave us this kind
of voice to me that was the big step
forward now it doesn't spit polish
better but that said there's something
really reflected about when it comes to
any kind of human-like experience
because you can imagine AI systems can
be quite different so for example we
build a system called deep listener in
2003 that when we fielded it and use
also why it was deep is it used lots of
contextual signals to understand better
what you were saying but imagine this
user interface versus the assistant it's
a little we scanned in you know that how
mm I that glass eye from the from the
Space Odyssey we scanned it into the
system I know it's not a great starting
point for great human compatible the AI
system but there it was on a box and
it's and when you talk it would be green
we changed the color and if it got
confused it would turn a little bit
yellow and I've got really confused to a
term red and you'd said you'd you'd slow
down and you'd start talking more slowly
Oh yellow back to green again so people
got used to this I as being the thing
you actually talked to and it's it's
making expressions to you in a very
different way
versus me trying or team Franco to a
human-like experience which then people
say you know yeah that's kind of creepy
I don't like the way that human looks or
sounds and so I'm going off to a
different direction is saying that it
might not be the best thing to try to
make people like things maybe we should
stick with these metaphorical scanned in
eyeballs and things that might just give
us signals and stay away from the
humaneness and - we can really get it
right completely and even then it would
be kind of lots of questions would come
up I hope that's a good answer yeah
Mike Mike you hold them back with that
Mike one question I have is more curious
about your comment and then the other is
just very specific but curious about
your comment is in the various
implications societal implications I
noticed you didn't mention anything
about jobs in terms of you know this
whole universal basic income thing if
people end up vastly unemployed you know
huge swaths of the population so that's
the sort of broader question and then
the very detailed specific question is
in the thing with the special doorbell
the safety conscious person in me was
wondering is the Machine able to figure
out the difference between a 3dtrue
person versus a 3d person with a photo
of someone that is Eric as opposed to
being Urich yeah so I underestimated how
much content I had and you saw me like
with a little bit of cognitive overload
doing secret skipping of slides forward
today especially on the societal side
which is you know each each was balanced
about one-third one-third and I ended up
giving short shrift to the last part of
the talk right i I had I I put more
effort into those topics so I love talk
to you offline maybe maybe after about
the issue of the economics AI labor in
the economy you know I think it's hard
to know what's going to happen
I was on a National Academy of
Engineering study actually nesic had me
a science study that came out about a
year and a half ago after two years of
work with experts in labor and work as
well as computer scientists trying to
figure out where things might go and the
basic conclusion was we needed more data
and the Bureau of Labor Statistics and
other sources should be providing more
data as we can help forecast better but
you know probably recommend people to a
great piece to look at it Tom Mitchell
and Eric B Olsen who actually co-chaired
that study just recently but two months
three months ago put out in science
magazine in policy forum a piece saying
let's not think about jobs as the grain
size let's think about what subtasks in
an ontology of task types might machine
learning accomplished in different
decades machine learning and planning
decision-making and then let's look then
look at jobs separately as what are all
the components of a job in terms of the
tasks jobs and require to get done and
then let's imagine if you had these
competencies and tasks how would the
jobs as they're currently defined shift
or change to be different kinds of jobs
based on these competencies first is
saying a job is replaced more like what
it's a radiologists do if it turns out
that the segmentation of radiological
films or images is pretty easy well you
have to really think through what it all
means for the patients and work with the
physician or during the film about the
plan it might shift the nature of a job
for example that said I'm uncertain
about what's going to happen and whether
or not we need to do some dramatic
things with taxing and Universal incomes
and so on some people believe they're
already planning on this they say we
will need to have that become the way we
do the economy in a world that's very
very full of resource from all this
wonderful automation and to free people
up to do creative artistic things it's
become caregivers and all the things we
do well as human beings
Oh on the so yes so the fact it's
actually a question asked so let me
repeat the question it was I love that
doorbell and I'll buy it at Home Depot
but I don't want someone coming up to
that thing after it's trained on you're
faced with three images and holding a
picture of me up and getting into my
home it's a great question
so people are looking at this and so I
just recently got a review at Microsoft
Research at a tech fair we call tech
fest and this problem has been addressed
with heat patterns and 3d analyses and
we told you no pictures wouldn't do it
but the human being would I think we
have we'd have to still work through the
security model there make sure it really
does the right biometrics so now it's
the human with the adversarial attack
here you can wearing the mask right yeah
yeah it's great I mean yeah I could have
given other examples I guess for the
door bill I guess is a little scary
but but you know but I think it's good
questions and we have to always ask
these questions all these methods right
because you know any technology we put
things out and then unexpected or
introverted things can happen even the
um that readmissions manager 30-day
readmissions right say okay well we
realized early on somebody called us
actually from one of the one of the
hospitals they said have you ever
thought about what happens when patients
are touched by your system and there's a
decision made by the actual machine
learned filter that changes the care for
a patient and overtime that system
running in a population will change the
distribution of sickness and wellness
and if the model doesn't correct for it
it's not modeling its own effects so in
general want to think deeply about
inadvertent and law and and bigger
effects than we actually maybe think
about at the first past in the
laboratory same with traffic you know
like you've always asked well if Google
Maps or Bing Maps says go here
is open what does that mean when
everyone goes there I mean we have these
interesting issues they don't think
deeply about sometimes as a community
yeah so other questions now I'll come
back to you in just a minute
any have another question yeah yes okay
thank you can you comment on how much
better an AI may need to be than humans
in order to be acceptable to humans so
some of the examples even the
self-driving cars the air rates probably
way lower with the self-driving car than
it is for human but any example of a
negative result is sort of outweighed by
humans and so how much better do you
think it may need to be and I know this
is probably sort of use-case dependent
in some ways right and it's a discussion
point we can have that over coffee to
live after the I guess after the formal
session here I think it is dependent I
think as an example Society will not
tolerate bizarre non-human style crashes
of cars even if their global use will
nearly eliminate all 36,000 deaths or so
in this country per year and many more
thousands of injuries that are lifelong
injuries with life or the implications
we will not tolerate it I just think we
won't as a community even with arguments
like that and maybe something like Elon
Musk's tweets about the accidents making
everything much safer and he's actually
correct but speaking as somebody who
actually suffered an accident and as the
whole section of my thought that I would
could spend on this on autopilot that I
was luckily safe from injury on I
believe that we could do a lot better on
many fronts with safety and reliability
of AI systems well globally that will
raise the bar on what we should expect
in terms of reliability and
trustworthiness and lower concerns
I'm hopeful there yeah you didn't have
time to go into it but could you say a
few words about AI in surgery
yeah I mean it's it's a broad area I'm
on the advisory board of for siesta
Johns Hopkins you can imagine that place
like Johns Hopkins C s department we
have lots of robotic surgery as a topic
it's that they're there they're well
known for surgical excellence at that
school Greg Baker is a leader there in
that work it's really impressive work as
what's possible especially now with the
popularity of The DaVinci system and
other systems like that where there's a
robotic linkage already being used but
it's given by stripping typically in
manual mode even though it's fabulous
set of tools to steady my hand and so on
and for going through and doing open
style surgery through laparoscope
laparoscopic entry points but you could
imagine all sorts of interesting work is
I have a video I was going to show if I
had time today of some work done showing
humans working with a machine at appiah
at the pediatric hospital in Washington
DC on a very complicated repair called
and asked the Moses repair it's kind of
me take two tubes like intestine and put
them together I'm showing how much
better the machine is at stitching then
a human would be and so you can imagine
there's also interesting possibilities
an interesting direction at Johns
Hopkins by the way is using AI systems
to automatically understand and
recognize the grammar of surgery to help
with this idea of the mix initiative to
know when surgeons are doing x and y to
happen next and have this hand back and
forth this volley of contributions but
secondly to understand expertise to
recognize expert versus non expert
surgeons and figure out what's different
and help with training surgeons it's a
really interesting area the most
exciting recent work is and Greg Hager
is the lead on this H a ger and I look
up his research and the team is using
deep neural networks in the open world
this videos right at the at during
surgery
segment and figure out what's going on
and to start doing coding and labeling
and tracking for education purposes as
well as quality management should I sure
related to what you've just talked about
so we have all this algorithm that are
pretty soon are already taking some
decisions like classifiers or decision
takers deep neural networks and
basically we have some data we train
them and we get the result but often we
don't know how this result was actually
achieved and when people start getting
decisions that their lives depend on it
like you ask for a loan for a bank and
he so you want to know why so the
question is there any research that
allows you to actually people to
understand because people start
demanding explanations like if the
banker says it you can talk to him you
can kinda reason with him but if you
just type into algorithm and there's
deep neural network which trained on who
knows what you'll demand explanations so
how this explanation would be provided
well well the good news the bad news
about this right the good news is that
it's a rising field of study as well as
an area being somewhat pushed along and
pressured by some regulations a famous
one is called GDP are coming from Europe
I think it's May 25th that's going into
force I got that right
that actually asks somewhere and one of
the Articles got the number of the
article used to know the number and I
gave a talk on this that people who are
touched by by consequential decisions
automated decisions made by an automatic
system deserve to understand in a
meaningful way the logic of the
processing actually this is actually a
regulation well so that that's a state
the bad news is it's hard in general you
know in 1986 over the paper looking at a
decision theoretic system that was
confusing adopters when it asked
recommend the next next question to ask
and I said not only this if it's really
it's really rich it's it's trust me it's
it's it's doing value information
complications expected value it's it's
got to be right looking at these
diseases it's trying to rule out and so
on and I realized that it was so good at
what I was doing is thought in a very
non-human way jumping way ahead and
doctors actually preferred to have a
slow down into these classes like benign
malignant waited by the probabilities
what a paper called you know the strait
between optimality and transparency so
doctors are more comfortable using the
system it can learn from it and another
thing was kind of a wacky idea like oh
ha understand ability of an expert
system that does decision theory is
interesting but going back earlier
explanation was central believe it or
not in the expert systems era the
rule-based expert systems days and there
were actual tutorials and papers being
written Randi teach did a paper on this
topic that doctors need to understand
but it was much easier explaining a
chain of rules now we're in the
statistical world and so it we're faced
with very interesting challenges and
there's interesting work going on local
explanations building models that are
suns and sums of components even if they
don't perform as well as a neural net as
the explanation sorts of explanations
and then people are looking at you know
what you do at neural nets sensitivity
analyses counterfactuals
it's a very wide open area we don't even
really understand what would be a
satisfying explanation to a human being
it's a psychology there as well you just
talked about GT BR and I was wondering
if you could address more generally what
you see is the proactive role of
the government both the federal in terms
of funding and infrastructure for basic
research down to state and local in
terms of regulations privacy etc I know
it's a kind of small question especially
looking at other countries like China
that have taken a really proactive
stance and trying to working with
companies whereas the United States were
more letting the private sector Drive I
mean what do you see as the proactive
role that government should or should
not be playing here so I so my current
leaning is so some people that are
worried about concepts like and use
phrases like artificial general
intelligence as a thing that's gonna be
snapped into but who are discovered and
then we're in big trouble to get things
right we're just concerned about really
powerful AI systems being controlled by
small numbers of people or surveillance
sometimes like surveillance think about
broadly about like having like we need
to regulate AI to meet its like that
sounds to me like we need to regulate
computer science because it's a very
broad set of disciplines it's not a blue
green gas that comes out of the vents
somewhere right and and if you've been
to press articles you'll think it's like
some materialist being discovered like
it's something like some sort of
radioactive material but it's actually
literally it's optimization it's
planning it's it's it's statistics and
so regulating that globally is funny to
me
however specific implications in domains
like transportation to me make a lot of
sense and might be very important in
certain areas so I believe that I'd have
to think more about this I don't -
because a statement I'm not being
videoed here
I believe it's it's it's it's likely
going to be the case that when a safety
critical system is filled it'll say in
an automated car that it's looked at
very carefully in terms of how data is
collected how accidents are reported
just like for airplanes right now it's
probably going to be the case that when
you feel the system in the open world
given the nuances of AI systems you'll
need to have a kind of a phasing phase 1
clinical trial phase 2 clinical trial
Marketing surveillance with reporting of
adverse effects I had a rash from a drug
it be reported by the unit in the air
system for the FDA you know um
when I had I'll say this on tape now I
had my Tesla accident what happened was
I was driving along on a curving road
and I had been on many times in
autopilot on this day for stochastics
uncertainties nuances the sunlight
whatever my feet the left in my tire
when it came to an intersection hit the
yellow line on the left side but the old
line was a raised painted nine inch high
piece of concrete and so a blow both
tires and took up the rear suspension of
the car and I thought wow um it pulled
over and I called Tesla and I said well
you know you weren't on a highway and
you weren't going more than 45 miles an
hour so we're not responsible here's the
towing company number and they'll take
care of you at roadside service but I
really wanted to report my case I wanted
to report the experience I wanted to
push a button that say look I hope
you're tracking this because here's what
happened I had eyes and ears on this
thing and I can and and then just a
month and a half ago and I feel
ethically challenged here someone was
killed in Mountain View and my view of
that accident reading the New York Times
article very carefully was that's sort
of the accent that I had but the block
was a bit higher it was a piece of cut
was up there was actually a divider that
was higher on 101 not this low thing on
85th Street near one hundred and
thirtieth Avenue and so if there was a
collection way to collect this
information and share it and if it had
to be regulated to have it happen
I say sounds like a good idea I want to
think about it some more but I can see
things like that domain-specific uses
and applications especially in fielding
technologies in the open world
Ava so I run the follow up from I guess
one question back on explanations so one
interesting sink you touched on but I
guess I hope you have more maybe can
respond more about is their human biases
and this learning systems often learned
from human experience yeah so that means
the learning system is encoding our
biases yes and sometimes these human
assisted systems are actually amplifying
our biases rather than helping them yes
so what do you think we should do to
turn this around and it's a major
concern and there's a whole conference
now that that's that but well well
accountability and transparency are
considered is important it's the
fairness that's the dominating concept
now can we build fair systems it's a
really beautiful area of research in
terms of what's a metric for fairness
what are protected variables what's
legally okay what's how do we detect
that there's bias in systems over even
over time to the dynamics of though of
the world but certainly we are
definitely in a situation where vicious
circles can be algorithmic and we're
challenged when it comes to even up
applications like public safety right
policing we know for and there are
studies that ACLU and other other civil
liberties groups that we have all sorts
of challenges with how we orient
ourselves to data sets and how are they
collected well you know there was more
observations of this part of town and
since the police we're looking over here
more they kind of confirmed that there
are problems in this part of town so put
more police there more observations get
more data about this part versus that
side of the tracks you can imagine this
goes into issues of gender and race
other there other dimensions of
demographics there are so many deep
biases in our society you know my wife
she saved my partner often points out
that even in this I think I don't have
did you check this again on video here
like even in the 60s apparently in the
United States women had to get the
permission of their husbands to even
have a charge card so you're telling me
we're gonna buy some society a few years
later it's deep and race in particular -
very deep so we have a group in the
ether committee just focused on fairness
and bias from Microsoft's point of view
and it's a central focus of the
partnership on AI as well and of course
as a conference whether the conference
now called fat splat used to be called
fat ml fairness accountable and
transparent machine learning and the
group was redly so figured out that it's
not just ml it's other algorithms as
well so now became fat asterisk and I
heard from Hannah Wallach my wandering
for that that's a fat splat is the new
name for the conference but it's in this
it was in its first year this year as a
formal conference but it's been like
three workshops - now so it's an active
area it's a very good comment it's a
really big danger with these systems
that network effect appears again it
shows it pokes through the slide and I
think about the network effects and the
possible vicious circle yeah great
questions by the way okay last question
okay it seems to me that unless you
believe there's something divine or
metaphysical going on in the neural
network of our minds I don't nor do I
that eventually and maybe sooner than I
personally might like you'll be able to
in fact replicate every human capability
intellectually I think it's somewhat in
genuine you say well people will get
different jobs if you're talking about
receptionists the question I have for
you I guess is how long will it seeming
that we both agree that you'll be able
to do everything that humans can do how
long will it be before you are obsolete
and the people in this room that do what
you do and we be should we not be
concerned about not you particularly but
what do people
do when they're all obsolete so I'm so
glad you asked this question as the last
question today I am my hope my hope is
and my belief is that the power and need
of human beings for human beings will
only get stronger in a world full of
automation and automated intellect and I
foresee maybe this optimistic the rise
of what I like to call a caring economy
where there's a lot of wealth around
from the automation but the top
compensated people are the best at
providing human touch
human connection human teaching pedagogy
and and it's just it's just the the
optimistic view that it might go very
well for Humanity let me just make a
comment again and I'll end with this
example and we can talk out in the
atrium in the lobby there's a we had
again a deep dive with our senior
leadership team at Microsoft with this
set of future projects and one of the
projects coming out of our China lab MSR
Asia was a system that could write a
beautiful song to deep neural network it
looks at songs and poetry China and it
writes a beautiful song with lyrics all
novel and people said by the way it's
got book book of poems by Xiao Weis but
I have at home now and I say wow it's
like you know it's like people say they
kept you know I didn't I don't
understand Mandarin but people have
tears in their eyes listening today a
song I said you know what when I hear a
song sung by a country-western artist I
want a human being who experienced those
lyrics I'll pay top dollar for that now
let's end there Thanks
[Applause]